كشف رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو ، مساء الإثنين ،
ما قاله: أسرارنا الجديدة
، أرشيف ميرون النووي في هذا
الجانب ، أجرت إيران تجارب
لتطوير أسلحة نووية ودعا مرة
أخرى المجتمع الدولي إلى
اتباع نهج الرئيس دونالد
ترامب ومعاقبة إيران السبيل الوحيد لفرض عقوبات على إيران.
أوقفنا المسيرة نحو القنبلة
وعدوانها في المنطقة هو
ضغط ومزيد من الضغط ، كان
الوحي الناتج عن المساعدات البصرية
شيئًا وعد به الزعيم الإسرائيلي المحاصر
لأسابيع ، وإن لم يكن
بنفس القدر الذي كان عليه في مايو 2018 ،
كذبت إيران عندما كشف نتنياهو عن إسرائيل
سرقوا الأرشيف النووي الإيراني في
عرض تقديمي في وقت الذروة ،
يقول المحللون الوحيدون إن أيًا من هذه
المعلومات لم يغير قواعد اللعبة ،
علم الموقعون على الاتفاق النووي
بشأنه منذ سنوات
، وقالت الوكالة الدولية للطاقة الذرية إنه لا يوجد دليل جديد
على أي عمل بشأن الأسلحة النووية بعد
2009 وخبراء يقولون إن أيا مما
عرضه نتنياهو ليلة الإثنين يظهر أن
إيران انتهكت د  آل أعتقد أنه أمر
محبط للغاية ما
ستحتاج إليه حقًا هو موقع نشط في
الفترة الأخيرة من أجل الإشارة إلى
أن إيران لم تمتثل
لالتزاماتها وأنت تعلم أننا رأينا
بعض الصور ولكننا بعيدون حقًا
أنه في هذه اللحظة لا يزال ترامب يقول
إن عرض نتنياهو العام الماضي
كان جزءًا من سبب قراره
ترك الصفقة النووية الإيرانية هذه
الصفقة الكارثية وكان ذلك بمثابة فوز
لنتنياهو ، ما نراه هو استقبال ثابت
وانتهاكات
يقول منتقدو إسرائيل.  الأمن
يبحث عن فوز آخر في
انتخابات صعبة بعد أسبوع ، انتقد خصومه
البيان ، حيث
قال بينيغان إن
استخدام نتنياهو لمعلومات أمنية حساسة
للدعاية يشير إلى
سوء تقدير ، حتى في أيامه الأخيرة
كرئيس للوزراء.  نتنياهو
لا يهتم إلا بنتنياهو إذا كان هدف نتنياهو
هنا هو أيضًا محاولة منع
لقاء بين ترامب والرئيس الإيراني
حسن روحاني يبدو
أنه فشل ترامب مشيرًا إلى أنه سيكون على
استعداد لمقابلة روحاني في الواقع
لم يكن الجذع
رد فعل على نتنياهو.
عرض معلومات من الأرشيف النووي
الذي رد وزير الخارجية الإيراني
جواد ظريف الذي أطلق النار على تويتر
قائلاً إن صاحب أسلحة نووية حقيقية يبكي
الذئب على موقع مزعوم تم هدمه في
إيران
أورين ليبرمان سي إن إن القدس